ALICIA: APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
HAPPY SATURDAY TO YOU.
GRIFF: THE GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA
MAKING A TRIP TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TO CHECK IN ON THE
STATE’S NATIONAL GUARD TO GET A
FIRSTHAND LOOK AT THE GROWING
CRISIS AFTER CALLING OUT VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS FOR NOT
MAKING A VISIT TO THE US-MEXICO
BORDER HERSELF.
JOINING US IS BRIAN KEMP, THANK
YOU FOR TAKING TIME ON SATURDAY,
YOU JUST HEARD A DEMOCRAT BORDER
STATE CONGRESSMAN HENRY CUELLAR
SAYING IT IS NOT UNDER CONTROL.
WHAT DID YOU SEE?
>> IT IS A CRISIS, UNBELIEVABLE
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
IN DECEMBER VISITING TROOPS
BEFORE THE CHRISTMAS HOLIDAY,
MUCH DIFFERENT RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS IN JANUARY,
THEY HAD 17,000 APPREHENSIONS IN
THAT AREA THEY ARE PATROLLING,
FEBRUARY, 28,000, MARCH IT WAS
62,000, THEY ARE GOING TO HIT 60
AGAIN.
THEY WILL HAVE 600,000
APPREHENSIONS THIS YEAR.
VERY MUCH DIFFERENT THAN IT WAS.
THE CARTELS ARE MAKING A LOT OF
MONEY SHIPPING PEOPLE ACROSS THE
BORDER, REALLY HAVE A STRATEGIC
PLAN.
THEY START THROWING KIDS AND
PEOPLE IN THE RIVER WHO CAN’T
SWIM TO DIVERT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS FROM GETTING THESE CARTEL
MEMBERS AND SENT PEOPLE TO BE A
DECOY TO DRAW ATTENTION TO THEM
AND FLOAT FORWARD RANGERS FULL
OF DRUGS ACROSS THE RIVER AND
GET THEM INTO THE INTERIOR OF
THE COUNTRY, DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT VERSUS DECEMBER WHEN I
WAS THERE.
GRIFF: YOU SAW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND I HAVE A
SOURCE, 2245 APPREHENSIONS.
IF YOU COULD GIVE ONE PIECE OF
ADVICE TO THE VICE PRESIDENTS
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE, WHAT WOULD
THAT BE?
>> THE FIRST THING THEY SHOULD
DO IS GET ON THE GROUND AND TALK
TO THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
DOING THIS EVERY DAY, TALK TO
THE TEXAS TROOPERS I TALKED TO,
THE GEORGIA NATIONAL GUARDSMEN
THAT ARE THERE WHO IN THREE
LOGISTIC MISSIONS FLYING
HELICOPTERS WITH THE BORDER
PATROL, MAINTENANCE AND WORKING
IN THE TACTICAL OPS CENTER TO
RUN CAMERAS THAT WERE MENTIONED
EARLIER AND GOOD UNDERSTANDING
FROM WHAT IS GOING ON.
THEY ARE BEING OVERWHELMED AND
PEOPLE WHO NEED MORE RESOURCES,
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP INTO
GOVERNOR AT IT AFTER BEING
BRIEFED BY HIS FOLKS.
THEY WILL BE SPENDING A FORTUNE
NEXT YEAR TO SUPPORT A FEDERAL
MISSION OF PROTECTING THE
BORDER.
IT IS TERRIBLE WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND TO SAY THE CRISIS IS OVER IS
NOT TRUE.
THESE CHILDREN, THEY CRIED ABOUT
MONTHS AGO AND MOVING THEM TO
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
AND I CAN TELL YOU PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND ARE WORRIED THE TITLE 42
IF THAT GOES WAY IT WILL BE
WORSE THAN IT IS NOW WHICH IS
HARD TO BELIEVE.
THIS IS THE WORST NUMBERS EVER
SINCE THEY HAVE BEEN KEEPING IT
ON PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER, THE NUMBER OF
APPREHENSIONS.
ALICIA: THE HEALTH CONCERN
MAXIMUM WHICH WE DO DEPORT
PEOPLE LET ME ASK YOU WHAT YOU
MAKE OF THE FACT THAT ON THE DAY
YOU WANT TO THE BORDER PRESIDENT
BIDEN CAME TO GEORGIA AND WAS
HECKLED BY ANTI-ICE ACTIVISTS.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE GOT TREATED
TO.
>> BUT GEORGIA.
>> END DETENTION NOW!
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
I’M WORKING ON THAT.
GIVE ME ANOTHER 5 DAYS.
>> DOES IT CONCERN YOU THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT GETTING THE
MESSAGE FROM THE BOARD OF
REGENTS YOU TALK TO?
>> I HEARD THAT ON THE NEWS
COVERAGE AND DON’T UNDERSTAND
THAT.
HE DOESN’T UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON THE BORDER.
INSTEAD OF COMING TO GEORGIA HE
SHOULD BE GOING TO MCALLEN,
TEXAS, OR ARIZONA OR THESE OTHER
PLACES AND GET A HANDLE WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY.
ALICIA:
GRIFF: YOU ARE INTENDING TO SIGN
SOME BILLS ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
>> OUR FIRST LADY IS DOING AS
MUCH AS ANYBODY IN THE COUNTRY
TO END HUMAN TRAFFICKING BUT NOT
ONLY THAT BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT
THE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, WE HAD THREE
ADDITIONAL PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THIS YEAR, UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN